it's been 16 years of no answers no
closer to finding this little girl
but now a fresh search concentrated on
this remote Reservoir
the Irish dam is just 30 miles from
where Madeleine McCann was taken from
her bed in prior to luge
the main suspect convicted sex offender
Christian B allegedly called this area
his paradise
he is currently serving a sentence for
raping a woman in the region from where
Madeleine went missing he denies any
involvement in The three-year-old's
Disappearance saying he'd been staying
in his campervan that night
the dam has been searched before as part
of a private investigation in 2008. now
Portuguese and German authorities will
spend the next two days scanning the
water and surrounding Woodland
Scotland Yard detectives are also there
some approach with cautious optimism I
think what's significant is that this
search is being led by the German police
the German police
um are are generally cautious by nature
but they've been absolutely adamant that
they have the right person in custody
and and that they know what happened to
Madeline and and that's an unusual
situation so so that makes me hopeful
the case has haunted the world and
decimated the world of her family
earlier this month they marked what
would have been Madeleine's 20th
birthday and reaffirmed their promise to
never give up on finding her Ashner Sky
News